today we're talking about sustainability
spanner a compute ga and live q a
i'm jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
google cloud aims to be carbon free by
2030.
we measure our progress along this path
with our carbon free energy percentage
which is now public for the majority of
our google cloud regions
we're sharing this data because just
like latency or cost
we hope that carbon emissions will
factor into your decision making
when moving to the cloud cloud spanner
recently launched a point in time
recovery capability
that provides complete data protection
against inadvertent deletion
or updates due to user error with this
capability
spanner now offers continuous data
protection with the ability to recover
your past data
to a microsecond granularity this helps
enterprises quickly fix data corruption
to reduce
risk loss of business and minimize
impact on customer experience
we're excited to announce the general
availability of a2 vms
based on the nvidia ampere a1 tensor
core
gpus in compute engine this is going to
enable customers around the world
to run their nvidia cuda enabled ml and
hpc scale out
and scale up workloads more efficiently
and at a lower cost check out the post
for a full rundown of how our
a2vms stand apart did you miss the first
ask google cloud
catch up with the recording of the live
q a session all about serverless
architectures
and don't forget to submit your
questions on twitter and youtube
with the hashtag askgooglecloud to be
featured on a future session
stay tuned for more details if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you